let me let me tell you a story uh a
story and a theory
hypothesis i was talking to some like 22
year old dude
um on the east coast a year or two ago
and he was talking about how he never
had a real relationship or anything like
that and i was like man you're 22 i was
like that's kind of that to me that's
crazy
and uh and i started i realized
something
when i was when i was a teenager and
when i was you know partying
college years and it was just like i
drank way too much man it's a drinkage
party non-stop all day i didn't go to
high school so i was just skateboarding
playing music being drunk going and
partying it was kind of wild
but the women that i would meet we
didn't have tinder we didn't we didn't
have any of these apps
so what would happen is the women i knew
in college
only knew the men they met in college so
who are the guys in college
well this this this chick's 19 years old
she knows some 19 year old guy
he's not got anything really going for
him he lives in a dorm he doesn't have a
car
but it's who she knows so she dates him
now he's 19
they you know become college sweethearts
or whatever maybe they get married maybe
they don't
there's a lot of people like that that's
what's happening not anymore
that's my theory so i saw this guy then
dating apps come out
now this college woman who's 19 or 20
opens up their app
and it's not just the 19 year old guy
that's what i said to this 22 year old
guys i'll tell you what your problem is
and this is not absolute i'm just saying
but
i'll tell you this is something you're
really facing that i didn't face when i
was younger i was like look i'm in my
early 30s
i'm wealthy successful i got a a a
conversion rv van i can take you to an
infinity pool on a roof
of this luxury casino and when i go on
these apps
how is a 19 year old college kid going
to compete with that so it's really
simple
i'm not i'm not trying to impugn the
honor of these young women it's very
it's very very simple
if there's a 20 year old woman and she
swipes
right on this like attractive 20 year
old guy to college and they're messaging
and she's also messaging a 30 year old
guy 30 year old guy says
how would you like me to pick you up in
my you know convertible
and we'll we'll drive to my house i've
got an infinity pool i just built
and the 20 year old guy says how would
you like to come hang out at my dorm and
watch movies and she's like man which
one sounds like more fun
there's more opportunity with the guy
who's already established dating apps
have opened that up and made it much
much harder
because now young men without the status
and the wealth are competing against
established men yes and adding to that
is
the 30 year old guy isn't just texting
one 19 year old
so he's not just taking one off the
market which would be you know
mathematically it would all kind of suss
out he's actually taking three four five
off the market
because he and he's making them all so
it's the weird thing is online dating
has ruined it for women because a guy
can just be like hey dude i need
n-u-d-e-s's and if you're like no it's
like okay
i'm the 35-year-old guy i'm gonna i'm
about to fly to paris
i'm picking out who i want to bring with
me on this trip you're going to send
them
no see you later going down the list of
the you have
not just your 19 year old you can't
compete but it's not just one girl's
been taken off the market now
it's really like four or five are being
taken off by the top dogs so you have
the
the top of the food chain kind of guys
having
a monopoly and then you have the younger
guys who then just check out and i want
to stress too like
more power to these women it's their
choice to be with whoever they want to
be with and and i'm not saying that
there's any violation of their autonomy
or agency simply because they're engaged
in this dating app game i'm just saying
there is a uh general hypothesis i have
that i think the math will pan out
that young men are less likely to form
bonds and relationships with women
because of the
competition in the market but then my
question is what happens when those 20
year old guys are 30 year old guys
without any dating experience but also
most importantly what's going to happen
to those 19 year old women that do
become 30.
there's this weird kind of invert axis
that happens especially around the age
of 30 i mean it's becoming later and
later on
but it's not good it's not good for men
when they're young
and it's not good for women when they're
older so this is causing a lot of
a lot of infighting that is causing a
lot of relationships not to happen
i i gotta say too i love like this this
always really really pisses off the left
but yeah i think it was okay cupid who
did this study on
so they would never do that again they
were all right they deleted them yeah
yeah they deleted these studies
it showed that i forgot what their mate
their their metrics were
but that women have maximum societal
value at young ages and men have
none and then around 28 men start going
up
and uh it's around 22 men start going up
and around 22 women uh uh i think 22 is
where like their highest point
yeah they peak at 22 to 25 and man so 25
flip it yeah at like 30. yeah so then a
man's hit in prime time at 28 to like 36
and then the woman on the decline so
then what happens which luke says is
if you're a 30 year old guy at the top
of the food chain you're going to be
like
why am i going to date a 30 year old who
was dating 30 year olds when she was 19
all through that when i can be i'm 30
years old i'm on top of the food chain
now like what are you going to do
and then women get mad because they're
like well i have a career this and that
and then and that goes to the survey
earlier it's like one one thing that
really
surprises women in a way that's
unpleasant for them
is most men don't care what your career
is you know
i hate to be the bearer of bad news but
you can say i'm a mid-level executive at
the whatever thing and if a guy's got
his own thing going on he's like well
that's nice i'm happy for you
congratulations for your success but
i don't know dude i'm trying to like
take a trip you want to like get on a
plane or you got to call in
sick at work or you got to get vacation
time or whatever yeah that
so that's actually something i
experienced i was i was in a
relationship with
a fairly uh prominent media individual
and it was just like you're doing your
thing that's really cool
then we're both doing our thing and so
there was no real opportunity to
actually spend time together
it's like if you've got your career and
your career is the most important thing
i got to be honest
all we really did was like sleep in the
same bed like
night comes and it's like how was your
day that's great and then we didn't
really do anything together
there was no shared mission right and it
can't be that way
and like i'm i'm like what you said
earlier is if you're if you're like 19
years old
and you get to like have fun that's your
life man you know men or women can do
whatever they want to do
the question was how mathematically that
sets us out so then you have men kind of
check out
and then men are kind of i don't know
man they're kind of lame and then
i know all these you know because when
you become a little bit more prominent
you know women will kind of start to
talk to you a little bit more and a lot
of attractive women be like oh man no
guys hit on me and i'm like look
man i don't know what you're trying to
do here but i'm not the guy who's gonna
compliment you
and then i found out no no they weren't
fishing for compliments men don't
actually make a move
so i would be at places and it's like
junior high
you know i'm 43 it's like junior high
all over again so there'll be four girls
over here
women or you know whatever young women
over here four guys over here they're
kind of like looking and the guys don't
make moves anymore either
they're on their app they're like can i
swipe and they're like i don't know make
a move or whatever whereas when you were
you know my you know when you were
in college your age or my age you had to
go make a move dude
that's the crazy thing i was thinking
about that when i was you know like 18
19 20
we every weekend we would be at some
random house party and it was literally
just dudes walking around
hey what's up to women and talking to
them and then they'd feel it out and
then they'd either leave or that was it
like
congratulations you met someone now
you're gonna go hang out or do something
now it's all like pre-screened on an app
you know bumble the the woman who
invented bumble
bee but becomes a billionaire where only
the women can make the opening move
like these apps have have i'm you know
what i'm not going to say this i don't
know what the long-term effects of this
are going to be so i'm not here to make
like a harsh criticism of
the dating scene or the choices of men
and women just pointing out the
differences that i've experienced
and what i think might be affecting men
and women at certain ages well
i mean the we've we see the results and
i'm happy to make a prediction
the results are if you're like a guy at
the top of the food chain you're king
kong again you're an aristocracy
you have all the cards on the table
we've returned to an aristocracy where
you can live
as a man a life that you couldn't have
lived unless you were like royalty
this time i was talking to a friend
about this i was like i think
like a lot of this feminist liberation
stuff and apps have been the greatest
thing
for like douchey alpha guys oh for sure
without question
because now it's like they're they're
going on apps and they're
swiping around literally every woman
then they're getting then
they wait for the woman message them
back and they just like i love these
memes where like one guy will message 50
women the same thing and go
oh man that's that you all saw that oops
thinking it was going to be like a blind
carbon copy or something
yeah so what i what i've noticed from a
lot of this there's a lot of regular
dudes
clueless and cut out and there's a lot
of guys that are
prominent successful wealthy who are
just
owning the game and they're doing it
unabashedly
because they're leaning into the sexual
revolution too which is okay
their guys are just like okay i just
don't know monogamy dude
you know you got a problem with that
fine with me whatever this is kind of
the way it's going to be and everything
is free nobody's being compelled to do
anything
and so then the competition becomes less
because more and more people check out
it creates this like vicious cycle
so then you do that the winner of all
this stuff are the the top one
one to ten percent of men are the people
who won
from the dating apps and that and
okcupid showed that
okay cube but they they had all this
great you could never do this now it
shows how far canceled culture is they
deleted one on ugliness
yep like if you're an ugly guy you're
doomed and they deleted it because
they're like
well then they did one too where when
you call somebody a douchebag
those people the guy with the shirt off
in front of the corvette actually gets
yes hit up more by the women so if
you're like
they said they said although many women
will stay in their profiles
if you're not wearing your shirt don't
bother they actually tend to respond
more to men who are not wearing shirts
right so all the empirical data show
that if you're the douchebag
guy take your shirt off wax your
car show pictures of you by the eiffel
tower you're going to actually get head
up
and if you're the respectable guy i'm
very nice you know i
i read all the feminists lit you're not
going to get anything but that's of
course why they had to delete it because
the empirical data was in direct
conflict with the narrative
there was there was one they had
specifically about attractiveness and
what they found is
men will message women similar to their
own level of attractiveness
so it's a bell curve but women
overwhelmingly overvalue their
attractiveness and only try going for
the best of the best guys
so it's something like what is it like
twenty percent of the guys get
ninety percent of the messages right
something like that and it's all the top
tier best of the best
chiseled six foot five you know models
can you think about like shirts off
tribalism in general
you'd have a group of women and they'd
all have one guy
that they would use for the semen to
have the children
and that that's how it went and now it's
like we're reverting back to that almost
it's unfortunate and that's what that's
evolving to a new version of it yeah
we're devolving and that that's
revolving or devolving i don't know well
i i'm kind of either i think it's a
change or whatever
well that's where i'm an
institutionalist so you know that's why
i can represent john roberts and
maybe jordan peterson's point of view
where he got trouble with enforced
monogamy because people
can't have an adult conversation but if
you don't if you don't want to be like
the middle east
where one guy has all five women and now
four guys have nothing to do but blow
things up
or get angry get radicalized the the
idea that if we want to live in a
socially cohesive stable culture i want
people paired up i want people having
kids at an early age i want them
thinking about the next generation
i like i said i'm a cocky
institutionalist i like
social stability and in social order and
i think you know
probably less than jordan peterson does
but that's where jordan peterson got in
trouble
it's called enforced monogamy right and
what happened was you had i think some
feminist writers
thought what he was saying was you would
take women and force them to be with
with men and what he was saying was that
just social and
like yeah like cultural like hey you
should get married you should think
about having a family well here's how it
changed
when you were how i'm 43 i'm probably
the oldest in the room right
yeah everyone okay yeah so enforce
monogamy would just be when you were
like my age if you cheated on your
girlfriend you were like a scumbag
you know even your guy friends you're
not getting like high fives unless the
other guy was kind of like a scumbag
right you're just like jesus dude like
your girlfriend's nice what are you
doing
that's enforced monogamy it isn't that
you have to do it but there's just a
cultural norm
well another thing we have to understand
here people not mating people not having
partners
leads to social decay leads to crime
leads to violence
leads to radicalization leads to uh you
know
again i saw one of the stats i forgot
the exact kind of parameters of it but
it was
people who don't get laid usually tend
to be blowing themselves up or attacking
people or to be some of the most
creative i mean that's
that's a that's a problem man no one no
one deserves to get laid like no no
woman owes any guy
anything like that so i don't know how
you solve for that
i'm assuming the data is probably true
i've heard similar things but
i don't know what are you supposed to do
in that regard well nothing as a society
i mean that's the whole
point is that you're you're not saying
that it you should change it or that you
can change it
it is what it is to quote you know
donald trump which got him all in
trouble is
i think it's a bad situation societally
but what am i going to do
that is what it is but also let's let's
make the point here that a lot of
institutional
establishment mainstream media hollywood
powers promote this larger message of
promiscuity of not having partners of
not having families
there was even advertisements by the nih
in the united kingdom telling people
do you want to have your video games or
do you want to have a baby do you want
to have your high heels or do you want
to have a baby as if having a baby
something bad and taking away from you
having fun playing video games
are you wearing high heels or doing
whatever you want to do but it's almost
it's almost like
they just want you to be a kid they
don't want you to grow up you know did
you post that meme earlier the high
heels and lipstick okay
because i saw that and the weird thing
just is like a married guy is
the uh it's actually sex gets better
when you're with a person longer because
you know what like boundaries are and
you know things aren't going to go too
far and everybody kind of like knows
what's going on
so i saw that i was like actually these
women don't know that in
like a committed relationship they're
going to have more intimacy they're
actually have a better time
so the idea that like you're gonna have
a kid and you're never gonna wear a
lipstick
and lingerie and high heels is probably
the opposite you're more likely to do
you know forgot your wife i grew up
with tv telling me marriage was bad and
having a family was awful i mean
i i you know what show i really could
never i hated was married with children
yeah
yeah and the reason i hated it was not
because he was you know he it was
because he was a loser
it was because he always lost the only
the only episode i remember where
al bundy actually won was when he
punched a guy in the face
and then they joked that he sued him and
won for hurting his fist on his face
and it was because like the show was
making a point that the system was
broken
but like i watched the show you know it
when it would come on i was i was young
and he was always just miserable he
hated his kids he hated his wife they
hated everything and i was like
what is this this is awful we weren't
allowed to watch it well our parents
wanted this as well
look at the way a family is
characterized in in mainstream media
television and sitcoms and movies look
at the way that the father
is portrayed look at his characters look
at
what he stands for look at how he acts
he's a dumb dopey fat
dope that doesn't give a damn about
anything and is absolutely miserable so
so
seeing that representation plays on the
subconscious of so many young americans
of so many young children
and it's the complete utter opposite of
what's happening in china
china huge population crisis because of
their one child policy
they're literally building databases of
fertile women inside of beijing
with millions of people yes china is
building databases of how fertile women
are
in beijing and that's and we only know
about that because that was leaked
there's other stuff that they're doing i
mean they're creating machines that suck
out your
life the male energy uh family-friendly
show here i'm trying to watch my word
here
but you saw i don't know if you guys
seen this but the chinese machine
reproductive matter
yes yes they're literally building
machines that build your re
that suck out your reproductive matter
they're they're trying to make males
more masculine
they're not alone they're not allowing
immigration uh
they're a very nationalistic country uh
lydia looks scared they're
horrified but that's happening that's
the reality of the world that we're
facing and if you compare what
if you compare what china's doing to
what the west is doing
it's a completely different approach and
one of them is going to be successful
another one is not thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you